[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
nous sommes heureuses de vous retrouver
avec brigitte boucher bon genre de
registre j'entame est aujourd'hui pour
commenter l'actualité de la semaine
notre invité est eric coquerel
bonjour vous êtes député de la france
insoumise de seine-saint-denis et c'est
brigitte qui vous présente
et oui eric coquerel vous êtes à un
insoumis bien avant votre élection en
tant que député et les filles en 2017
vous avait écumé les partis
contestataires de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire dès l'âge de 25 ans
passant par le mrc le mars où le parti
de gauche alors contre l'europe actuelle
vous avez et théorisé le plan un plan b
contre pour sortir de l'union et de la
zone euro vous avez boxer vous aimez
boxer dans l'hémicycle pourtant votre
sport avoue c'est la voile vous avez
fondé une agence de communication chargé
du vendée globe
est-ce que c'est utile d'être un
communicant politique ça peut ça peut
apprendre à mieux parler mais je jeu
pour envoyer une coupure c'est le jeu je
travaillais dans la voile entre le
communiquant je ne fais pas de la
politique entend communicants et je n'ai
plus l'âge ans je me suis retiré parce
que j'estime qu'on doit pas continuer à
avoir une activité professionnelle quand
on exerce son mandat de député il y
aurait pu y avoir conflit d'intérêt
oui puis je trouve que je vois pas
comment on fait les deux opus alors vous
allez communiquer beaucoup sur les sur
les retraites puisque après l'échec de
la commission le projet de loi arrive
dans sa version initiale dans
l'hémicycle ce lundi la france insoumise
compte bien jouer une nouvelle fois
l'obstruction pour repousser le vote du
texte
la majorité fait des propositions pour
réparer le couac du projet pour deuil
d'enfant trois semaines seront accordées
ainsi qu'un accompagnement financier et
psychologique
le président affiche un virage
écologique au pied du mont blanc il veut
faire de 2020 une année décisive à face
à l'urgence climatique 1 et on commence
par le premier thème de cette émission
la réforme des retraites bientôt à
l'épreuve de l'hémicycle à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
où les oppositions affûtent leurs armes
avant l'examen du projet de loi
retraites en séance publique dès lundi
le texte sera soumis aux députés
mais l'ensemble de la gauche la france
insoumise en tête comptent bien freiner
son adoption
tous les recours possibles sont sur la
table après l'échec de la commission
spéciale stéphanie des pierres 23 heures
mardi soir après 9 jours 75 heures de
discussions et plus de 5500 amendements
étudiés
la présidente de la commission spéciale
jette l'épongé en cet instant il nous
reste 13 1987 amendements à examiner
j'ai convoqué notre commission spéciale
demain matin mais compte tenu du nombre
d'amendements que je viens de rappeler
il ne me paraît pas possible qu'elle
achève en temps utile la discussion des
articles du projet de loi ordinaire
cet inédit à l'assemblée pour la
première fois face à la déferlante
d'amendements plus de 22000 une
commission n'achève pas l'étude d'un
projet de loi pour les communistes il
aurait fallu prévoir plus de temps
pourquoi nous arrêtons j'ai bien compris
que le gouvernement souhaitait que dès
le 17 février commence le débat en
séance mais nous sommes le parlement
souverain
à droite on renvoie dos à dos le
gouvernement et la france insoumise qui
a déposé dix neuf mille amendements
les républicains estiment que les
français sont prises en étau d'abord
d'un côté par le gouvernement par un
mauvais calendrier
comment peut-on croire que sur une forme
comme celle là une semaine de
commissions spéciales étaient suffisants
personne ne peut croire à ça et ensuite
par la france soumise qui sont les
idiots utiles du système et qui
finalement parmi tant d multipliant les
amendements les uns à côté des autres
abymes la représentation nationale le
parlement les discussions en commission
n'auront donc servi à rien ou presque
les députés reprendront le texte initial
du gouvernement dans l'hémicycle la
france insoumise a promis autant voire
plus d'amendements motion de rejet
motion référendaire motion de censure
cour constitutionnelle la gauche encore
en réserve tout un arsenal d'outils pour
contrecarrer le gouvernement la bataille
continue dès lundi eric coquerel damien
abad vous accuse d'être les idiots
utiles du gouvernement est ce que vous
n'allez pas finalement sortir affaibli
de cette séquence dont je crois pas
tous les retours que nous avons dans la
population section greg aussi ceux qui
sont qui les soutiennent dont vous savez
qui sont en majorité dans le pays au
contraire on nous dit ok vous avez fait
vous faites votre part du travail pour
essayer de bloquer cette réforme mais
monsieur damien abad est assez amusant
parce qu'en réalité nous avons copié sur
les républicains
la méthode employée depuis le début du
quinquennat il le faut car ils déposent
autant d'amendements identiques que
nombre de députés
là c'est lui qui le faisait nous l'avait
jamais fait jusqu'à maintenant là on
estime que la gravité de cette loi nous
y contraint est-ce que sur le fond ce
travail n'est pas contre productif
finalement grâce à vous le gouvernement
il a eu la garantie qu'on ne toucherait
pas un poil de son texte avant l'arrivée
du texte dans l'hémicycle alors non vous
avez écouté un bourguignon et vous avez
entendu les membres du gouvernement
c'est un échec pour eux parce que en
faisant ça on trouve que le calendrier
choisi les méthodes choisies c'est à
dire celle d'une procédure accélérée
pour bien comprendre précieux accéléré
fait que on a on n'a pas besoin de
finaliser le texte en se donnant le
nombre de jours nécessaires mais on
décide d'une butée bah ça ça marche pas
voilà on peut pas faire passer un texte
de cette ampleur en contournant le
parlement comme on le fait d'ailleurs
aussi avec les ordonnances finalement
sur le fond vous n'avez pas vraiment le
moyen d'influer sur le texas qu'on ait
finalement pas plus dans une bataille de
communication vous l'avez dit surtout à
avoir à témoin l'opinion publique dans
une guerre de tranchées
voilà on assume il déclare la guerre à
un des deux piliers du patrimoine social
français la question des retraites
nous notre travail à partir de la c1 les
ralentir autant que possible de façon à
ce que le mouvement social reprenne un
second souffle
et puis de aussi s'en servir pour
argument parce que vous avez remarqué si
vous avez suivi la commission je sais
que c'est le cas quand nous tiens on n'a
pas lu le bottin on a pas on n'a pas
fait des amendements bottin on a
argumenté
on est très souvent on les a poussés
dans leurs retranchements et se sont
révélés des aspects négatifs de cette
loi qui jusqu'à maintenant était pas
dans l'actualité qu'elle a vraiment
servi à quelque chose pour vous cette
commission spéciale
oui en tout cas la manière dont nous ont
amenés oui et je le vois là encore sur
les vidéos où les gens ont appris des
choses sur cette loi qui fait d'ailleurs
que entre le lavant commission spéciale
est là prêt dans les sondages
l'opposition à cette réforme n'a pas
cessé d'augmenter donc vous voyez bien
qu'apparemment on a servi à quelque
chose
alors vous vous avez
préparez vos arguments vos armes pour
lundi pour la séance publique
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu qu est ce
que vous allez faire à partir de lundi
et on recommence voilà on va déposer
plus de vingt mille amendements cette
fois ci on sera pas le seul je pense que
le groupe j'ai cru comprendre que le
groupe communiste va aussi augmenter
largement son quota pour pareillement
essayé de freiner et d'éclairer
l'opinion publique sur la nocivité de
ces toits et en même temps nous allons
dès le premier jour avec le parti
communiste le parti socialiste déposé
une motion référendaire
parce que ce que nous disons c'est que
soient ses deux retraits et si le
gouvernement comme il le prétend a fait
une loi qui est bonne pour tout le pays
facilement facile à expliquer soutenu
cas sinon c'est le référendum quand vous
avez une situation bloquée de ce type
ça peut être aussi l'issue par le haut
de revenir aux urnes vous avez aussi
prévu une motion de censure
oui mais l'a pour l'instant malaisie
niati socialiste ne nous suit pas sur
cette nécessité on estime justement
qu'il faut le faire dès le départ ont
ils disent à la fin de la loire moi je
trouve que l'on trouve que c'est
maintenant que le combat doit s'engager
enfin on espère les convaincre avec le
temps alors vous le savez sûrement deux
responsables de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée les députés à la
république en marche
laurent saint martin et emilie cariou
ont écrit au premier ministre pour lui
demander des éclaircissements sur le
financement de la réforme en termes de
compensations de hausses de salaires
pour les enseignants
vous vous posez vous les mêmes questions
que se sont devenus des alliés pour vous
ils sont bien obligés à un moment donné
de reconnaître eux mêmes des problèmes
dans la loi sur cette histoire
d'enseignants par exemple il ya fort à
parier que ça va être
anticonstitutionnel d'ailleurs le le
conseil d'état prévu à la danse parce
que pour bien comprendre comme on va
pénaliser une profession de manière très
forte escale en réalité est là à la
système de 2,2
de rémunération qui va là là là pénalisé
dans la réforme par point ce qu'on a
imaginé c'est que dans cette loi on
annonce une prochaine loi valorisé mais
ça c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
comprenez que les parlementaires actuels
ne peuvent pas s'engager sur nous à
venir donc voilà tout ça à mon avis
c'était une façon d'essayer ils y
arrivent pour de calmer les enseignants
ils essayent de boucher les trous comme
ils peuvent
oui vous pensez pas qu'il y ait vraiment
de l'électricité dans l'air dans la
majorité en tout cas on n'a pas
l'impression que ce sont des députés
playmobil sont pas sereins ils sont pas
sûres vous croyez pas edouard philippe
quand il dit
tout cela est très sain c'est un débat
normal on l'a vu parce que dans les
débats ou c'est vous voyez esther vous
avez ils ont quatre cinq piliers qu'il
nous réponde etc qui essayent de
défendre tant bien que mal cette loi qui
nous sortent d'ailleurs des perles
monsieur turquois par exemple c'est
intéressant qu'est ce qu'il nous dit à
un moment donné il me dit qu'ils font
une loi pour permettre de bien vieillir
au travail à la ça montre que c'est un
changement c'est une différence totale
avec nous on pense qu'on ne doit pas
vieillir au travail on pense que les
gens ont le droit de vieillir en
arrêtant de travailler est par contre en
s'adonnant à des loisirs à d aider des
activités associatives etc
donc on voit bien que ça il ya deux
logiques différentes matières un recours
de l'art conseil constitutionnel ou pas
je pense que sur beaucoup beaucoup d
aspects de cette loi oui y compris le le
l'autre scandale que nous avons dénoncé
que le conseil d'état a dénoncé 29
ordonnance c'est à dire que il y a des
éléments de cette loi est pas anodin qui
concerne certains moments des dizaines
de milliards d'euros qui en vérité ne
seront connus qu'après et pas par le
parlement fin c'est une manière
incroyable de deniers une fois de plus
le droit du parlement à légiférer
oui effectivement apprend dans ce sens
là la conférence de financement travail
pour gérard larcher le président du
sénat et à la chambre haute que l'examen
du texte pourra d'ailleurs avoir
véritablement lieu en l'écoutant
le collègue député et je dis vraiment
respect pour eux ils vont voter dans le
noir nous allons voter dans avec plus de
lumière puisque la conférence de
financement aura avancé mais je dois
dire que il ya quelque part une forme de
d'approché vis
et de ce que doit être un débat
parlementaire mais le gouvernement peut
toujours lever la procédure accélérée
tout moment à tout moment et je souhaite
qu'il le fasse et si ça lui apparaît
nécessaire moi je pense que c'est
nécessaire
est ce que si le gouvernement avait
relancé la procédure accélérée enfin un
peu de politique fiction c'est ce que
demandait d'ailleurs le sénat vous vous
aurez déposé - d'amendement est ce que
c'est parce qu'ils ont fait ça que vous
vous êtes à l'élection tout non je fais
parce que on estime qu'il faut les
freiner voilà c'est tout on le
revendique même s'il avait cédé sur la
procédure accélérée que vous aviez eu
plus de temps on aurait posé les
abandons mais en plus de ça pour bien
comprendre en réalité quand vous posez
autant vous déclarez des amendements par
député on les a pas tous défendu on le
savait ça permet que nous on est obligé
de faire une rotation et 17 mai on peut
pas bon donc ça nous permettait à chaque
fois d'être certain de pouvoir prendre
la parole donc voilà comment on a fait
mais là c'est simplement que ce
calendrier tient pas et le calendrier
pour la suite ne va pas tenir parce que
nous allons recommencer et très
vraisemblablement le 3 mars il y aura
pas de vote de cette loi à moins de
scénarios sont envisagés un mois le 49-3
mais vous envisagez de l'horizon or
après les municipales au moins déjà de
gagner toujours gagner est bon à prendre
pour mouvement social dès lundi on est
avec on a signé un appel nous les
députés français soumise avec des
membres d'associations d'attac de
copernic de quasiment tous les autres
partis parti communiste génération que
ces terres externe en acier artistes
intellectuels grand appel notamment pour
faire un comité national de soutien qui
commence avec une initiative lundi à
partir de 16h à proximité de l'assemblée
bon donc on compte bien aussi nous
continuer à soutenir les mobilisations
la révérence qu'elles se généralisent
qu'elle ce qu'elles grandissent pour
faire en sorte qu' il soit obligé de
retirer leurs lois ça sert pas emmanuel
macron ça qui apparaît comme un
réformateur
non il apparaît pour un casseur est de
plus en plus de 2 du système par
répartition parce que non seulement sa
loi va coûter très cher dizaines de
milliards d'euros de déficits qui vont
s'accumuler
j'ai pas le temps de vous expliquer dans
le détail mais pour plein de raisons
entre ce que vont rapporter les côtes
les cotisations qu'ils imaginent pour le
système par points
est ce qu'il faudra débourser
mais en plus de ça maintenant tous
montrent qu'en réalité c'est un
gigantesque recul du départ de l'âge à
la retraite 65 66 67 ans bon donc je
pense au contraire qu'il est tous est en
soin d'éclairer le pays eric coquerel on
va passer un second thème toujours à
l'assemblée l'exécutif et la majorité
ont tenté de réparer l'erreur du rejet
de l'allongement du congé en cas de
deuil d'enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après le couac sur le congé pour deuil
d'un enfant muriel pénicaud et le
secrétaire d'état adrien taquet ont
rencontré cette semaine les associations
pour améliorer la proposition de loi une
des heroes sénat alors pour la ministre
du travail
il faut aller plus loin que le seul
allongement du répit c'est bien que ce
sujet puisse être athée comme un vrai
sujet de société qui est beaucoup plus
large que le sujet du congé même si le
crochet fait partie des outils qui
peuvent aider les parents je suis
confiante que le la loi final qui sera
voté par les deux assemblées sera
beaucoup plus riches avaient contenu
beaucoup plus adaptée beaucoup plus
riche que la proposition soit initiale
eric coquerel vous entendez la ministre
finalement va arriver un dispositif
encore bien meilleure pour les personnes
qui font face à cette terrible épreuve
du deuil pour enfants parce que
finalement tout est bien qui finit bien
c'était un mal pour un bien
non je te fais parce que en réalité la
ligue en cause parce que si vous vous
souvenez sa manière de refuser cette loi
c'était de dire ça ne peut pas pénaliser
les entreprises
et là dans la solidarité nationale ont
classé la sécurité sociale qui va pays
donc c'est la solidarité nationale et
non pas l'entreprise
j'observe que par rapport à ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle disait au départ la
raison pourrait s'opposer à cette loi
les y gagnent cause mais ça à mon avis
ça va pas rectifié non pas l'erreur
c'est pas une erreur il doit assumer ils
ont voulu y connaissez la loi faut
arrêter et monsieur jan balik mais c'est
le genre a dit le vrai problème c'est
qu'on pensait pas que ça allait de vue
on fait mieux qu'en mai mais sur le fond
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
propositions il y aura trois semaines
pour
congés en cas de deuil d'un enfant
deuxièmement finances la méthode de
financement satisfait pas maintenant on
va pas nous est pas la solidarité
nationale non je pense que c'est je
pense que l'entreprise peut dans ces cas
là justement apporter apporté son écot
j'allais dire à quelqu un à un de ses
membres qui subit un deuil absolument
terrible une souffrance absolument
terrible et qui de toute façon on ne
peut pas être en état de travailler on
le sait bien c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le medef avait lui aussi protester
c'est que n'importe qui sait très bien
que pouvait pas demander à quelqu'un de
cinq jours d'être à nouveau à son
travail donc c'est une certaine logique
mais maintenant que même si les méthodes
de finalement je le conteste
tant mieux si ça permet d'avancer mais
ça ça je le maintiens que ce n'était pas
une erreur tout comme d'ailleurs
vendredi ce n'était pas une erreur que
on va en parler dans un petit instant
mais je voudrais que vous réagissiez à
ce qu'a dit le président de la
république aux députés il a dit soyez
fiers d'être des amateurs quand on voit
ce qu'on fait les professionnels vous
êtes un peu d'accord avec ça je
comprends rien à ce que je t'attaque à
l'ancienne c'est à dire ça un peu
bizarre comme le chef de l'état qui
devient vraiment officiellement le chef
de la majorité qui s'adresse à tous les
députés qui trouve sa campagne en marge
exécutif législatives excusez moi mais
je trouve ça un peu spécial comme
nouveau monde ont fait on fait on fait
difficilement fait vraiment on fait
vraiment mieux non je suis pas trop je
moi je trouve que isa bin le pays ils
abîment empêche le pays en général et
c'est ça qui qui qui complique tout
c'est qu'il n'assume même pas leur
politique ils ont besoin
il cassait les réformes il parle de
progrès social ils cassent la protection
dans les entreprises avec la loi
pénicaud il parle de meilleure
protection des salariés et c'est cette
cette distanciation ce décalage
à mon avis ça a aggravé sa aviv la
confrontation au pays parce que c'est
insupportable à entendre
alors il y avait un autre épisode cette
semaine jeudi les députés de la majorité
ont été mis en minorité sur une
proposition de loi du groupe liberté
territoire portant sur diverses mesures
de justice sociale d'eau
l'individualisation de l'allocation
adulte handicapé un texte adopté contre
l'avis du gouvernement
écoutez
donc 79 votants 75 exprimé majorité à 38
pour 44 contre 31 elle est adoptée
pendant pendant trois minutes le temps
de changement des textes elle est
députée elle même n'ont pas respecté
cette fois-là la consigne puisqu'il y en
a qui ont voté finalement pour cette
proposition ils sont pas une tombée
nouvelle fois dans le piège on pourrait
dire ils ont appris de leurs erreurs il
ya deux questions j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment un moment donné ils
ont imaginé aller contre ce texte je
parle du groupe la direction parce
qu'ils n'allaient pas assez loin
ce qu'il avait déjà fait rencontré sur
une aire de jeu mardi
c'est incompréhensible la deuxième
question c'est vous venez de le dire ça
le fait qu'il n'ait pas été mis en
minorité ça veut dire que à mon ami la
majorité de com en train de s'effriter
d'autant plus qu'il est plusieurs
suspensions de séance pour essayer de
faire revenir du monde
ils n'y sont pas parvenus je trouve que
c'est assez symbolique ski cp
l'opposition fait pas de la politique
politicienne quand même sur ces
propositions la non non mais finalement
ça a été adopté à ce que les cris
d'orfraie de l'opposition si c'est pas
un petit peu aussi de la comédie mais
puisque finalement ça a été adopté mais
ça n'a pas été facile
ils ont fait encore une fois des
suspensions de séance pour essayer de
rectifier majorité/minorité n'y a pas là
il ya quelques jours de ça vous l'avez
pas vu parce que c'était moi - moins
facile à comprendre mais il ya eu une
proposition de loi pour faire en sorte
que les retraites par capitalisation qui
sont placés dans les assurances et qui
ne sont pas données qui ne sont pas
rétribués à ce qu'ils aient qui peuvent
en bénéficier de forcer les compagnies
nation salle faire bon moi j'aime pas
les retraites par captation enfin c'est
normal que quelqu'un ils sont dus mais
on a au nom ils étaient minoritaires à
trois reprises au mont 10% en séance
jusqu'à être à égalité dans la séance
c'est une façon de 10 m de voir la vie
parlementaire qui moi mais désagréable
voilà je trouve que c'est pas bien et si
ça commence à s'effriter tant mieux
pourtant veut pas dire qu'en matière de
dollars d'allocation adulte handicapé le
gouvernement n'ait rien fait parce que
là la hache comme on l'appelle a été
revalorisé deux fois depuis le début et
justement c'est justement avec le
mécanisme qui va permetre cette loi
maintenant par rapport aux conjoints etc
c'était satisfaisant d'ailleurs les
associations saiz associations le
demandait ça fait un bouton c'est pas
nouveau il ya vu des amendements
proposés par parle plus on part nous par
le parti communiste
bon je suis content que cette fois-ci
enfin ça débouche parce que
il aplatit dans la construction quand
même comment vous appelez à plus de co
construction de travail allonge après la
parlement un moment donné les députés à
pouvoir voter des amendements des lois
de l'opposition avec lesquels ils sont
d'accord sans respecter une consigne
comme ils le font depuis le début du
quinquennat je pense que la démocratie
parlementaire en serait rovigo ray allez
on passe à un autre thème à présent dans
cette émission va parler d'environnement
nouvelles priorités des manuels macron
[Musique]
au lendemain du 4ème conseil de défense
écologique
le président de la république s'est
rendu au chevet du mont-blanc et de la
mer de glace
ce glacier au recul inquiétant une
visite symbole qui n'a pas convaincu
tout le monde
hugo lemonnier emmanuel macron dans les
entrailles d'un glacier en voie de
disparition
le président de la république s'est
affiché durant une heure et demie aux
côtés de scientifiques des images
destinées à faire du massif le plus
connu des français
un symbole du péril climatique la mer de
glace a perdu 130 mètres d'épaisseur en
30 ans le chef de l'état fait donc de la
défense de l'environnement sa priorité
pour la fin de son quinquennat l'année
2020 en la matière sera une année
décisive pour la biodiversité c'est
l'année où nous pouvons commencer à
changer les choses si nous savons pâtir
le cadre d'actions nationales
internationales et commencer les
transformations en profondeur mais dès
la fin de son discours le président de
la république est attendu par 250
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites
et parmi eux des habitants de la vallée
de l'arve au pied du mont blanc une zone
parmi les plus polluées de france de
quoi susciter l'inquiétude de certains
parents mes enfants sont toutes les deux
à thématique on a tout seul dans le coin
maintenant des enfants qui sont malades
qui sont très malades
rien n'est fait pour la pollution parce
qu'on
nous oublie alors du côté de
l'opposition on dénonce déjà les mesures
annoncées par le président pour
préserver le mont blanc là c'est un
sommet de la foutaise pour moi tu es là
le mont louis saha sommet de
l'hypocrisie fiston demande à emmanuel
macron qui est président la république
il n'est pas président du conseil
départemental de haute savoie c'est pas
légiférer sur qui va pouvoir grimper au
1 rue du mont blanc c'est de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures structurelles sur
comment on fait pour que les moins de
gaz à effet de serre dans ce pays et
pour ça eh ben il faut qu'ils aient
moins de camions qui le traversent alors
emmanuel macron a maintenant trois
semaines pour convaincre les électeurs
de son tournant écologistes et les
coquerelles votre collègue françois
ruffin parle de sommets de la foutaise à
ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu exagéré
quand même il ya eu cette visite qui
intervenait au lendemain du 4ème conseil
de défense écologique avec le plan qui
avait été présenté par elizabeth bornes
et qui a comité de défense de sauvegarde
du ministère de l'écologie fait par tous
les syndicats qui représentent 85 % du
personnel
pourquoi parce qu'ils craignent la
disparition de leur ministère ça fait
maintenant 10 ans et ça continue à
s'amplifier entre 2015 et 2022 à hauteur
de - 20% des effectifs que les effectifs
de ce ministère se réduisent alors
excusez moi chaque année avec le budget
oui oui non et c'est le ministère qui
souffrent le plus alors qu'on nous
explique que c'est une priorité
donc si vous voulez je crois pas du tout
qui mêle macro va empêcher la fonte des
glaciers par contre la faune des crédits
publics alloués à l'écologie et
notamment à ce ministère ça il le fait
en permanence salua d'hypocrisie l'an
écologique des manuels macro quand on
regarde notre dame des landes fin de
repas ce qui fonde la montagne d'or en
guyane loi anti gay ce prix je veux pas
dire qu'avant la montagne devront
malheureusement c'est pas certain mais
toute chose toute chose a été conquis
par la lutte sap a été donnée corps ce
que vous citez là comme exemple et je
vous fais remarquer que dans le même
temps les gaz à effet de serre émis par
la france sont toujours très largement
supérieur à aux engagements des accords
de paris donc je ne vois pas où est le
bon bilan et je vais vous citer autres
choses la réforme des retraites quelle
réforme plus productiviste que cette
réforme des retraites qui estime qu'en
réalité la solution c'est que nous
travaillons toujours tout
plus longtemps et davantage ses traits
productiviste comme l'idée qu' on
répartit pas le temps de travail les
richesses mais qu'on produit reproduit
en produits toujours plus donc je trouve
que sa politique est une politique
productiviste qui sait tourner le dos
aux urgences de l'heure et que tout ça
c'est de la communiquer ce qu'il n'ya
pas aussi un problème le problème c'est
que les français aujourd'hui ils veulent
tous plus d'écologie on voit dans tous
les sondages
mais ils sont pas toujours prêts à faire
les efforts nécessaires à prendre le
train plutôt que la voiture
accepter les champs d'éoliennes etc on
le voit il ya quand même une vraie
difficulté lorsqu'on arrive sur le
concret avec avec les français vous
c'est pourquoi ils prennent le train que
la voiture
vous avez vu le prix du train
aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est démesuré
c'est ça les joueurs ont donné on peut
pas faire une écologie punitive qui
s'attaque à des français qui ont déjà
des problèmes et que leur pouvoir
d'achat et en leur disant c'est vous qui
devez faire l'effort quand le
gouvernement et quand l'état d'abord
n'attaque pas forcément les plus gros
pollueurs qui souvent sont exonérés de
taxe justement avec des niches
écologiques des niches à l'écologie qui
sont catastrophiques je pense à des
grandes entreprises comme total et qui
en plus de ça fait une politique qui ne
va pas justement dans le sens par
exemple de prioriser le train en fermant
des en fermant dégâts en fermant des
lignes en ouvrant à la concurrence en ne
faisant rien sur le prix des trains moi
je vous dis une chose je trouve que le
train devrait toujours être plus
économique qu'un voyage en voiture et la
société comment ils associer les
français l'attendaient manuel un cran
avec la convention climat croyez que la
convention climat c'est bien gentil mais
ce que ce qui aujourd'hui est en train
de faire la convention climat toutes les
associations toutes les associations
ça fait belle lurette qu'elle apporte
les mêmes conclusions donc là aussi vous
me permettrez penser que ça a beaucoup à
voir avec le marketing politique et peut
avec la réalité d'une politique qui
lutterait contre le réchauffement et
être ainsi à quelques semaines des
municipales municipal d'ailleurs et bien
benjamin griveaux le candidat de la
république en marche à paris a décidé de
retirer sa candidature après la
divulgation de vidéos à caractère sexuel
qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette
décision il ya deux choses soit ces
vidéos étaient illégales c'est à dire et
dans ces cas-là ça doit se passer dans
la justice soit n'était pas et a priori
c'est le cas puisque j'y comprends
que celui qui les avait diffusé explique
que c'est une relation consentie et je
trouve que c'est une façon indigne
d'attaquer un responsable politique ou
quiconque d'ailleurs en diffusant ce
genre de vidéos et je pense que dans ces
cas là ceux qui ont diffusé ces images
doivent être poursuivis par la justice à
ce stade et selon ce que l'on connaît du
dossier merci eric coquerel d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci dame
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
[Musique]